there welcome welcome welcome in to
another edition of Market takes today we
are breaking down breaking out diving
into Really Gonna explain exactly what
we saw from today's blowout way higher
than expected U.S retail sales report I
am Dion raboen your host reporter for
the Wall Street Journal uh thank you so
much for tuning in I know you could have
been anywhere in the world but you're
here with me and I appreciate that look
today's U.S retail sales report was a
big one because it really solidifies a
lot of the worries a lot of the fears a
lot of the expectations that folks in
the market had about the economy uh the
economy may be doing a little too well
we're going to talk through all of that
we're going to talk about what the
report showed how that compared to
expectations we're also going to talk
about why this report matters and this
is a big one retail sales can kind of be
hit or miss today's retail sales report
was a big one because it really
confirmed a lot of what we had seen from
previous reports looking back at January
and kind of talks about the new
narrative for markets and the new
narrative for the economy so a big
report today of course we're going to
talk about the market reaction we're
going to talk about the environment
coming into this report and how the
outcome of what we saw from today's
report and I think today's market action
will be very interesting in terms of
setting the tone for the future uh so
we're also going to talk about that and
then of course we're going to talk about
what comes next for both markets the
economy everything else so diving into
it let's get into the numbers first of
all retail sales Rose three percent
month over month this is the biggest
increase in a year so going back to
January 2022 as you see right there up
on your screen this is the biggest
increase we've seen in retail sales from
the previous month going back for a year
now if you look you saw those two
reports you see right there on your
screen November and December coming into
this report we had seen retail sales
declining moving lower well now we have
seen retail sales Spike up and jump and
the fastest Pace in a year saying no no
no the trend is not for this decline to
continue the TR we are setting a new
trend where perhaps in one month it's
not a trend make don't forget one month
does not a trend make but we are seeing
a reversal of what looked to be a trend
of retail sales being lower being
negative and now turning into a
different direction so just wanted to
put that chart on your screen to
illustrate what we have seen from retail
sales going back a year uh this really
blew out expectations expectations for
for about a 1.9 increase this is a full
percentage point and then some increase
over what economists surveyed by Dow
Jones had expected and that 1.9 percent
was pretty high considering that we had
had negative one percent uh decline in
retail sales in December and in November
had had those were the first two
negative reports in a row that we'd had
in about two years so this completely
changes the trajectory analysts had been
talking about the potential for this
report to really exceed expectations
even coming in but I think this exceeded
even some of the higher expectations
among economists car dealers were a big
part of this Auto Sales surge during the
month gasoline station receipts we're
seeing a rise in oil prices that again
that's going to put some pressure on
some of these increased consumer
um you know consumer sentiment reports
that we've seen City had expected about
a 2.4 percent increase in retail sales
Bank of America actually hit the nail on
the head they track their own uh credit
card and debit card spending data and
their economists have predicted had
predicted exactly this this uh this
report their economists had predicted
exactly this result three percent
increase on the headline number as well
as a big increase in the control group
which strips out some of those more
volatile aspects of the report so Bank
of America's credit and debit card
spending actually showed a five percent
increase in household spending year over
year in January compared with a 2.2
percent increase in in December so more
than doubling the increase year over
year from January through to December
U.S retail sales are on excluding Autos
according to a MasterCard survey had
increased almost nine percent year over
year in January with retail e-commerce
spending growing five percent or 4.8
percent year over year so we saw Bank of
America data we saw MasterCard data we
had some of this real-time data coming
into the report showing that Americans
were increasing their spending and
increasing the pace that spending that's
not good news when you want to see
inflation numbers come down also we saw
Social Security checks increase 8.7
percent at the start of the year that is
the largest inflation adjustment in
decades and that's going out to about 70
million Americans so we saw a number of
things pushing this number higher now
that government piece where Social
Security checks folks who are on Social
Security and Social Security SSA things
like that got a bigger than expected
increase most folks probably didn't
expect to see the big difference in what
they got in that January check and that
may have contributed to this so this may
not be sustainable we will see but again
a lot of folks also spending that uh
that extra holiday bonus money some of
those holiday bonuses some of that extra
Holiday Cash maybe they got from Grandma
Grandpa aunt Susie things like that
we'll see if this is sustainable but a
real turnaround in retail sales report I
want to jump into the details gonna nerd
out with you just a little bit a little
bit I know I know I I don't want to get
too nerdy for you but we're going to
nerd out just a little bit here I want
to quote something that my man Joe Bruce
Willis he's the chief Economist at RSM
he pointed out that the key control
group that feeds into GDP increased by
1.7 percent on the month that's a big
increase excluding autos and excluding
gas increased by 2.6 percent on the
month
and X gasoline sales then when you price
out gasoline sales which were big
increases that Rose at 2.6 or I'm sorry
that advanced at 3.2 percent so even
when you take out gas Autos things like
that the big things that push this
report higher you're still seeing a
solid increase in retail sales that
shows you this is broad-based this is
across the board increases in spending
um Joe Bruce Willis says the economy
remains overheated and rates need to be
increased remember Joe Bruce Willis
talked to the FED he has direct
conversations with those guys as the
chief Economist at RSM but he is also an
advisor to the Federal Reserve he knows
what they're doing he knows they're
thinking he has conversation with them
he says that rates need to be increased
that's a direct quote I also want to
talk about my man Muhammad al-arian he
is the chief advisor to Allianz and the
president of Cambridge and Queens
College he says quote look for this to
do two things to markets that the jobs
report also did though to a lesser
extent pushback recession calls and
nudge up rate calls as they and expect
higher rates and expect a push back not
a not a removal of recession calls but
push back recession causes and later in
the years and potentially moving into
2024 or later in 2023 as a lot of
economists and asset managers had
predicted that rates were going to stay
high we were going to lead into
recession then the FED has to respond to
that recession a lower rate and that
gets the economy in the stock market
booming again because you've got those
low rates you can borrow money for
cheaply you can borrow money cheaply and
then go out and do things like add some
things to your home maybe buy some new
furniture things like that well this
pushes that further down the road and
pushes those rate calls up higher it
also shows the U.S economy not cooling
the FED really wants the US economy to
slow down wants people to stop spending
money so those prices stop Rising we're
seeing that that's not happening that
last retail sales report in December as
I mentioned was down one percent this is
a complete reversal and a reversal in a
big way so why does this matter to the
Market when we look out at those asset
markets and we're going to talk through
those don't worry about that but the big
picture response is that this changes
the narrative again remember going into
the end of last year we had this
expectation for things to slow down
recession worries were coming in folks
were a little bit douring and down and
bearish on the market then the start of
this year you saw that kind of that flip
that switch get flipped and folks were
bullish you saw that risk Rising you saw
uh cryptocurrencies jumping high-flying
tech stocks jumping a lot of the risky
assets in the market really taking off
and you saw those bond yields coming
down you saw a new environment and now
ever since that jobs report that really
started the other people said uh oh
that's not good increasing jobs report
that we saw at the beginning of February
from January then we saw CPI earlier
this week say inflation slowing down but
not as much as expected now we get this
retail sales report today and that shows
no no no no inflation is Not Dead rumors
of inflation's death have been greatly
exaggerated and that could mean some big
things to worry about in the market the
big thing my man torson slock he is the
chief Economist at Apollo Global
Management he said something on a recent
wsj podcast I thought was very
interesting he talked about the no
Landing scenario folks have talked about
a hard Landing or a soft Landing well
Torsten slag is saying we could be
looking at a no Landing scenario as in
inflation just doesn't come down baked
into a lot of the and a lot of the
assumptions about the market this year
was this expectation that one way or
another inflation is going to come down
talked about this in a recent video this
basically investors are saying we know
that inflation can't just keep going
higher it's got to come back down well
was it going to be softer is it going to
be hard Torsten slack is saying well
maybe we're looking at a no Landing
economy maybe inflation doesn't come
down and that is going to throw a monkey
wrench into a lot of expectations and
asset management allocations projections
all of that stuff for this year this
really confirms and solidifies it to
start the year we are not seeing
inflation cool off and go away we are
seeing inflation sticking around and
that is going to force some folks to
reevaluate what they think about the
market
listen the good news about the economy
because three percent retail sales
that's pretty good news in a vacuum but
that could be bad news could mean more
rate hikes from the Federal Reserve
rates staying higher for longer Deutsche
Bank actually came out even before this
report was released and said we are
revising our expectations and our
outlooks we think the FED is going to
raise rates to more than five and a half
percent we think they'll stay there for
longer that impacts everything it also
means the economy is not responding to
the fed's actions the FED raised rates
at the fastest Pace that they have since
at least the 1980s maybe the fastest
they've done in history last year and
the economy is still showing resilience
consumers are still going out spending
prices are still Rising that's not a
good sign because it means maybe the FED
needs to take more drastic action one
could say maybe it means the FED needs
to reevaluate what they've done and
consider that maybe the economy is not
responding to their actions the way that
it always has but that's not how these
guys think and we've heard from them
we've heard from Fed chair Jay Powell
we've heard from New York fed President
John Williams we've heard from a lot of
folks in the FED who say no no it just
means we need to raise rates more raise
them higher keep them higher for longer
some folks have said hey fed uh clearly
you're not getting it maybe you need to
try something different but the FED is
not looking at it that way and it's all
about the FED listen we got
unprecedented stimulus from the federal
government the three trillion dollars
care three trillion dollar cares acts we
got the uh American Rescue plan from
President Joe Biden we also got that
almost trillion dollar uh stimulus from
president Trump on the way out uh going
in 2020. so we've gotten about six
trillion dollars of federal stimulus
pushed out there the Federal Reserve
nine trillion dollars worth of Doubt of
money added to its balance sheet these
are huge actions and this is a lot of
money it's just sloshing around in the
economy it's not going away even with
the FED raising rates we've also got
something that hasn't been talked about
a whole lot unprecedented corporate
profit margins you had the uh net profit
margins for corporations rising to about
14 percent that was unprecedented never
happened in history corporations had
never made that much profit on their
sales in the history of some of these
accounting metrics and they were making
that as this inflation was Rising higher
so we are seeing big things that are
pushing inflation higher and they're
clearly not going away but there's a but
there's always a butt right we are
seeing net profit margins falling and
that could be bad news to the stocks
markets bad news for the stock market as
there have been worries about earnings
estimates being too high about folks
being a little too Rosy about the
outlook for stocks uh the Blended net
profit margin for the S P 500 for Q4
2022 that's lace one is 11.3 now not
only is that lower than what we've seen
these historical numbers that's lower
than the five-year average and that's
lower than last quarter's net profit
margin and it's way lower than the 12.4
percent net profit margin that we saw a
year ago so if this is the actual print
net profit margin which is an estimate
right now for Q4 it would be the lowest
one reported since the end of 2020
that's a big decline all right and so
we're seeing net profit margins for
corporations really start to hit the
skids we're also seeing Americans
borrowing a ton of money Consumer Debt
and credit Rose at a record Pace last
year and delinquencies now we're up
about 40 percent year over year
according to data from RSM
that's not a good mix we're seeing a lot
of worries about credit we're seeing a
lot of worries about the economy at the
same time as people are borrowing more
money at the same time as we're starting
to see people not pay back that money
and get hit with those delinquency fees
while the cost of borrowing money is
rising at the highest Pace credit card
rates are the highest they've ever been
so we're seeing record borrowing as
borrowing rates are record highs we
talked about this in our inflation has
sparked record credit card debt video in
October of 2022 check that out if you
haven't this retail sales report though
keep in mind there's only a partial
picture doesn't include things like
travel housing and utilities the
Commerce department will have a report
out about that later this month be sure
and check that out so before I leave you
you know we got to check in on the
markets we're seeing stocks down across
the board but not a huge reaction I
think because some of this is already
priced in because we've seen that
real-time data so we're seeing stocks
down we're seeing bond yields up but
just a little bit you know you're not
seeing a huge sell-off in bonds because
again we had seen this move of higher
you've got at the six-month treasury
yield up at about five percent that's
the highest it's been since 2007 so we
had seen some of the stocks lower bond
yields higher uh the big move I think
has been really in the currency Market
where we're seeing kind of across the
board the dollar had been lower and now
it's kind of picking back up you're
seeing the dollar up higher against the
British pound dollar up by about half a
percent against the Euro and you're
seeing the dollars start to rise that's
going to make more that's going to make
things more expensive it's going to make
corporations it's going to hurt their
profits again this could be a major
warning for the stock market and I don't
think investors right now are factoring
that in as we're just seeing some
smaller sort of moves on the stock
market listen
wrapping it up here this report backs
the The Narrative that we had coming in
that after that jobs report after that
CPI report this retail sales report kind
of confirms the economy is not slowing
down adds a little bit of nuance to it
one thing I don't want to do is throw up
this chart here of the conference
board's leading economic indicators
index and as you see there on your
screen over the past few months we have
been consistently moving lower that's
those business surveys where they reach
out to business owners purchasing
managers as they're called if you look
out at a number of indicators including
the stock market things have been
getting worse and they have been getting
significantly worse they haven't been as
bad as they are right now according to
this index since 2007 you see there at
the beginning of your screen 2007 was
the last time we saw indicators this bad
for this long consistently so just
wanted to put that on your screen to
just illustrate what we were seeing and
what this environment means the odds for
recession have been pushed back but they
have not been pushed out that's
something to keep in mind listen here
here's what to watch for next now we've
got the President's Day holiday coming
up next Monday but don't forget tomorrow
is a big day we get the PPI inflation
numbers that's what businesses are
paying for their materials we know that
when business prices rise usually they
pass that on to Consumers they have been
for about a year now housing starts and
the Philly Biz Outlook the New York fed
debt and credit report watch that that
will be big because it if it continues
to show consumers taking on more debt
that could be a sign that folks just
can't afford it but they have to keep
borrowing on piling onto their debt
loads this is a story that I think is
not being covered enough in financial
media the increase in consumer borrowing
and credit because people are saying I
don't have enough money but I got to
keep buying stuff then you're going to
watch for that leading economic
indicators report on Friday that's going
to be updated so we will see the latest
the latest report on that that chart
that I just showed you we'll see if that
keeps moving down or if maybe that
ticked back up and on Tuesday we will be
right here for Market takes talking
through the existing home sales data and
that's going to tell us about the
housing market the thing most sensitive
to increases and changes in what the
Federal Reserve does listen this has
been Market takes I know you could have
been anywhere in the world but you were
here with me and I thank you for that I
am your host Dion rabone we will do it
all again right here on Market takes
next time